hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
neuen episode
geschrieben wir starten direkt rein mit
dem verkauf eines war wie p30 pro also
eines handys und der interessent möchte
von dem verkäufer wissen aber das ganze
produkt auch ins ausland verschickt
irgendwie fertig der sich da allerdings
und schreibt stattdessen kannst du ins
ausland scheißen so weit kann ich nicht
scheiße sorry
also hier werden ganz klar grenzen
überschritten
und wie teuer ist eigentlich der versand
kroth
ja das hängt ja generell davon ab wie
hoch die bauchschmerz grenze ist halo
leider muss ich ihnen absagen ich hatte
heute die maschine noch mal aufgebaut um
zu sehen ob alles topp ist ich will man
fragen der maschine über meine katze
gefallen die maschine ist schrott und
mein arm gebrochen tut mir sehr sehr
leid liebe grüße und jeder
hat man das gehört somit
nichts gegessen ist aber auch scheißegal
ich glaube auf jeden fall dass jeder der
eine katze hat weiß dass diese
geschichte gar nicht mehr so abwegig ist
und apropos katzen meine lieben freunde
beim nächsten ebay verkauft die man
eines supreme champion kolar jacke für
herren bis 600 euro sehr geile jacke man
denkt sie jetzt wahrscheinlich dass er
da jetzt irgend ein foto noch irgendwie
mit reinpacken ö er packt einfach ein
foto von seinen beiden katzen rein
ja
ich denke mir vor seiner aufnahme immer
mensch heute lassen wir das niveau hier
ist es aber ganz schnell wieder irgendwo
hier und hier verkauft jemand sein
mountainbike und ein interessent fand
ein verkäufer halo ist das noch da ja
würden sie das für 30 euro abgeben
könnte auch sofort kommen ich finde die
mitte ist mit 40 euro da ein guter deal
ich habe jetzt einfach am straßenrand 1
mitgenommen
trotzdem danke
er tut es einfach schnell von ebay
kleinanzeigen zuber straßenrand anzeigen
hallo ihr lieben ich verkaufe diese
beiden hausnummern wegen viel kauf ich
wohne in der 24 kosten pro haus nummer 7
euro und das haben bei ihr an
bei sowas
glauben an die menschheit als nächstes
verkaufte jemand einen gaming stuhl zum
angenehmen gamen für
420 euro also es muss wirklich ein
brutaler stuhl sein der da was
dafür müsste man ja schon einen
ratenkredit nachdenken eine summe von
420 euro kannst nicht auf einmal zahlen
für seinen stuhl das ist aber auch schon
mega überleitung zum gesponsorte
frutigen die freunde wirklich mal ganz
kurz den spaß beiseite vielleicht ist es
ja schon mit dem einen oder anderen
passiert dass man beim kauf irgendwie in
den überteuerten ratenkredit
reingerutscht ist das ist der
mittlerweile beim online-shopping gang
und gäbe dass einem das beim
bezahlvorgang angeboten wird kommt ja
die fran ins spiel
die film findet es unfair wie große
banken mit ihren kunden umgehen und
welche kosten sie verlangen und deswegen
helfen sie ihren kunden dabei wie ihren
bestehenden kredit niedrigere zinssätze
zu finden apa afp
geht einfach in die app und macht ein
foto einer aktuellen kredit abrechnung
oder eines kontoauszugs und annie fans
technologie analysiert darauf den ob die
app für euch ein besseres angebot zu
besseren konditionen machen kann und
wenn euch endlich finden angebot macht
könnt jetzt ganz einfach in der app
direkt annehmen und direkt sparen das
cool es allerdings bis man das angebot
annimmt ist der prozess komplett und
verbindlich und komplett kostenlos somit
könnt ihr einfach und risikofrei checken
ob ihr geld sparen könnte das auf jeden
fall gern mal ab erster link in der
video beschreibung gern mal drauf klickt
man mit dem kot luca 20 spart ihr sogar
noch mal 20 euro auf euren von nsn
refinanzierten kredit bei ihr zweiter
mit in tibet bei dem nächstenliebe
versucht nämlich jemand ein auto und ein
interessent fragt ihn wie viel ist
letzte ich suche ein auto ich verkaufe
nicht okay sorry kein problem bist du
bulgarien nein doch okay
ich frag mich gar nichts mehr verkauft
jemand einen kleiderschrank mit
schönheitsfehlern ich habe keine ahnung
was schönheitsfehler sind allerdings
fragt einkäufer wie sind die maße und
der verkäufer schreibt richtig alm
anfang das gespräch noch mal von vorne
an starte mit halo oder guten morgen du
schaffst das arch mit ohren du kannst
mich mal und ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
bin hier sogar auf der seite des
interessenten bei warum muss auf seiner
seite wie ebay-kleinanzeigen alles
begonnen werden mit sehr geehrte damen
und herren ich will das und das bruder
das ist kein vorstellungsgespräch person
möchte einfach die maße von den beim
nächstenliebe fl verkauft jemand eine
antiquität ehre ich hab keine ahnung ob
das wort existiert auf jeden fall eine
relativ alte weinflaschen irgendwie für
sammler oder irgendwie sowas und
interessent fragt den verkäufer hey
irgendwelche beschädigungen am etikett
oder sonst wo die flasche ist schon
reserviert falls sich das anderes ergibt
kann ich nicht melden viele grüße ich
zahl aber fünf euro mehr habe das geld
schon bekommen kann ich nicht machen
alles gute hab keinen geburtstag
hallo ich habe interesse an dem rad sind
70 euro in ordnung unsere schmerzgrenze
ist 150 euro 100 euro und eine packung
ibuprofen für die schmerzen
mittelfinger
ich glaube ich hätte ihn vor 100
verkauft einfach für den job am nächst
liebefeld verkauft die man ein motorrad
und ein interessent macht ihm ein
unschlagbares angebot denn er schreibt
ich gebe dir 200 euro sofort auf sowas
wäre ich gar nicht erst antworten hast
du doch du vollpfosten da besser ein
voller foster als ein lehrer forsten wie
du was ist das denn für ein dummer
spruch kannst du nicht verstehen dafür
ist die kuh zu niedrig deinem namen dein
vater deine kinder ab
[Musik]
die welt so schnell teilweise
eskalierten beim nächstenliebe verrieten
käufer und verkäufer wieder komplett
aneinander vorbei denn der verkäufer
schreibt morgen ist die abholung 14 bis
16 uhr ok also montag meine ich und an
dem montag um 12 56 antwortet er dann
noch mal auf sich selbst weil er noch
keine nachricht bekommen hat noch
interesse der käufer antwortete
daraufhin bin da bin da eine minute
später schreibt allerdings nein danke
bin da aber nein danke also nein ja nein
vielen dank
hier verkauft jemand eine menge kondome
einfach aus dem grund ich brauche nicht
mehr
ist aber süß weil es ja irgendwie heißt
es erste freundin hat hallo christina
ich brauche ein stabiles sofort kann zu
sagen ob das sofa stabil ist inhalt
stabil können wir noch über den preis
reden dass wir stabil danke und einen
stabilen sonntag in aus stabil
ich brauche es gar nicht an spannung bei
diesem nächsten ebay verkauft jemand
eine grimmige kartoffel und die sieht so
aus
wie kommt man auf so einen stuss
gesagt hat er das sagen 70 jährige bei
diesem nächste ebay fail sieht man
direkt dass jemand eine keinohrhasen dvd
verkauft ich natürlich als großer
matthias schweighöfer fan weiß da
dementsprechend direkt bescheid die
sache ist allerdings dass er das ganze
nicht als keinohrhasen dvd titel sondern
als keinohrhasen
nah dran bruder kommen wir nun
allerdings zu einem langen chat verlauf
auf ebay und zwar verkauft jemand eine
tv bank aus holz und ein interessent
fragt ihn nach hast du auch noch andere
teile oder nur das longboard hey ich hab
nur die tv bank die so nicht komplett
weil ich nur die tv bank gekauft habe ja
aber wieso nichts komplett gekauft ich
brauche komplett da kann ich dir nicht
helfen ich habe nur die tv bank kannst
du noch das andere kaufen und mir dann
verkaufen natürlich nicht für denselben
preis wieso sollte ich das tun damit ich
alles komplett kaufen kann verstehst du
dich wenn du mir das geld gibst damit
ich das kaufen kann verkaufe ich
selbstverständlich wieder zurück ja aber
ich kann nicht so viel zahlen ich dachte
du kaufst es und verkaufte es mir dann
ist das ja billiger weil schon gebraucht
warum sollte ich um die einen gefallen
zu tun - geschäfte machen man kann doch
mal sozial sein so
bin ich aber auch
sozial sein
es geht ja nicht immer nur ums geben
das ganze leben ist ein geben und nehmen
und immer nur dem ausgleich sein
wie jan
oder spaghetti mit bolognese
das ist alles
ja ich glaub ich das wieder langsam
beenden ich habe schon eine verrückte
von daher meine lieben freunde